(ethereal music)
Okay, well, here's Maternity Care I.
On this particular one, nothing to disclose still.
We're gonna take a look at really the prenatal piece
and then in Maternity Care II,
we're gonna look at some of the intrapartum issues
and medical issues.
Oh, you know what that is?
That's where babies come from.
It's a cabbage patch.
That's me.
Aw.
No, it's not.
(everybody laughs)
Let's start with this question.
Nausea and vomiting in early pregnancy is very common.
Although often called morning sickness,
it can occur any time of the day.
Which one of the following
is considered first-line pharmacotherapy?
Diphenhydramine, ondansetron,
some vitamin B6 and doxylamine, or give methylprednisolone?
Okay, so it is a combination of vitamin B6 and doxylamine.
That is the correct answer. This is first-line therapy.
Some of you with a few gray errors,
remember, this drug used to be compounded
in something called Bendectin,
which was taken off the market
because they were concerned about birth defects,
and nobody had time to fight that
'cause these are cheap, inexpensive drugs.
Okay, now here's the etiology,
we don't know what causes it, but it's very common.
Typically, in four to eight weeks is when it starts
and will last up to 13 to 14 weeks.
Early treatment tends to be very beneficial
in terms of preventing progression
to hyperemesis gravidarum, which is very uncommon.
About 1% of people will develop this, okay?
Now, as we think about non-pharmacologic measures,
dietary changes, frequent small meals,
bland food, high carbs, low fat,
combining extremes like sour and tart,
don't be thinking the patient has gastroenteritis
and therefore, why would they wanna eat spaghetti, okay?
You eat whatever you wanna eat.
One of my favorites was I had a colleague
in my former institution, she was pregnant, vegetarian,
and during pregnancy, all she wanted was hamburgers.
(attendees laughing)
That's it.
Emotional support,
psychological help can be very beneficial here.
A lot of people can come really depressed
and have affective changes secondary to this.
Now, how do we start with this?
Well, we can convert the prenatal vitamin
to folic acid only.
Ginger in any form. This survey data.
Your mother knew this.
That's why she gave you ginger ale when you were sick.
And then consider acupressure bands.
The P6 area is over the wrist.
Pharmacologic options.
Over the counter is B6
and you can find doxylamine in over-the-counter sleep aids.
Sominex is one of them.
This is compounded in a prescription.
You can give Diclegis or Bonjesta.
It's just that these are very expensive,
so they can just take it over the counter
and you adjust the schedule based
on the severity of the symptoms.
Our next question,
which one of the following screening tests
should be offered in routine prenatal care to all patients?
Serologic testing, Pap,
testing for chromosomal abnormalities, urine analysis.
Okay, so the correct answer is C.
You do not do a urine analysis.
You do a urine culture, okay?
And now, in the 21st century,
you know, it used to be advanced maternal age we did testing
for chromosome abnormalities,
everybody gets offered testing.
And it's rare that somebody doesn't accept it,
but most importantly, they get to find out what?
The sex.
The gender or sex of the baby.
I should say sex of the baby.
And that's very important because they always tell me,
"If I don't know, what about my reveal party?"
It's a baby.
Okay.
Okay, so here are the initial prenatal visit labs.
Pap, only if they need one.
Although my daughter went for her,
you know, for her routine prenatal visit,
and they gave her a Pap sheet.
I'm like, "Meredith, why did you have one?
You just had one a year ago."
"Well, they just did one on me." Oh gosh.
That's why we waste so much in healthcare every year,
the equivalent of the GDP of the Netherlands
'cause we're doing stuff over and over and over again
without thinking.
Please think. We hope critically.
Okay. All of these are what we do.
Now, it's a urine culture
to look for asymptomatic bacteriuria.
Now, why do we look at a CBC?
Well, there's a whole big thing on anemia.
We know that iron supplementation decreases the prevalence
of anemia at delivery.
We know that iron deficiency anemia is associated
with a couple things like low birth weight,
less than 2,500 grams.
Now, low birth weight in and of itself,
people think, "Oh, that's just a smaller baby.
What the heck?"
Actually, low birth weight infants are at increased risk
for every known chronic disease.
Preterm delivery, perinatal mortality.
The ACOG says all pregnant women
should be screened for anemia, but this is a consensus.
And if you meet those thresholds,
you should be treated with supplemental iron
in addition to your vitamin.
Here's the USPSTF. They have an update in progress.
Screening and routine supplementation,
currently, it's an I recommendation.
Insufficient evidence to say this makes any difference.
Now, what about STIs? Hep B, syphilis, HIV, all women.
Chlamydia and gonorrhea, it's based on risk.
I'm younger and/or engaged in high-risk sexual behaviors.
It does not recommend screening for chlamydia
in women not at increased risk,
and we don't know about gonorrhea.
HIV, all pregnant women get offered this
as the first prenatal visit.
They have routine opt-out testing,
meaning it's part of the package.
And if you don't wanna have it done,
you can say, "No, I don't want that done,"
just like I can say, "I don't wanna have a CBC done."
If they have not been tested, then you can do it in labor.
If it was positive, you would proceed with treatment
and antiretroviral therapy for mom and baby,
you wouldn't wait for confirmation.
Asymptomatic bacteriuria, you gotta do a culture
and it has to have a single bacterial species,
which is pathogenic.
E. coli is what's most common.
Unless it's Staph saprophyticuss, it's a contaminant.
Now, it's present in about 2 to 7% of pregnant women,
not because they're pregnant,
just because they're at increased risk.
Those who have bacteriuria are at increased risk
for preterm delivery.
This does not increase
or the risk for asymptomatic bacteriuria does not increase
as you move through the pregnancy.
That's why we only test for it once
unless you have sickle cell trait.
Those women are at increased risk,
and therefore, they get a urine culture every trimester.
Treatment, it's seven days.
Single-dose regimens are not effective.
Cephalexin, we typically use amp? No.
High rates of resistance.
You wanna do a culture to make sure that they've cleared it.
Now, one caveat on any culture during pregnancy,
regardless of why you're getting it,
if there's any CFU/mL of GBS, they get treated.
Now, what are the antibiotics in pregnancy we think about?
You can use anything.
Please do not get hung up on sulfonamides
and nitrofurantoin, okay?
If that's all you got, you'd use it.
HSV, you never screen for this
by serum antibody look evaluation ever, okay?
'Cause everybody's got HSV antibodies, probably.
We do it by history.
If you've never had it before
and all of a sudden, you have an outbreak during pregnancy,
as long as you've had seroconversion,
so you've got IgG, your risk of labor is small.
Now, if you have a history of HSV
and you have been treated
during the pregnancy for an outbreak,
the recommendation is to put those patients starting
at 36 weeks on suppressive therapy.
You decrease your rate of cesarean section
for recurrent genital herpes.
Now, some people, regardless of whether you had an outbreak
during the pregnancy, will put the patient
on suppressive therapy at 36 weeks, okay?
But if they have a prodrome or active lesion
at the time of labor, then they are offered a cesarean.
Now, everybody now does screening for varicella
by immunoglobulin assay.
However, the recommendation is to do it by history.
And as we said on the very first day,
90% of reproductive-age women who say,
"I've never had chickenpox,"
will be seropositive for the VZV immunoglobulin.
So, only 10% will ever need VZIG.
If it's negative, unsure, you can get up titer.
If they're non-immune, that 10%,
you can vaccinate 'em postpartum.
Cystic fibrosis recommendations, we screen everybody now.
We offer that to everybody, okay?
It used to be based on history,
family of origin, et cetera, et cetera.
It can now be offered to everybody.
No routine screening, hep C, HPV, parvovirus B19.
Now, one word on parvovirus B19,
this is a embryotoxic, not teratogenic.
The fetus is gonna be at greatest risk
within the first weeks after the maternal infection
if they have never been infected before.
These patients typically are at increased risk
if mom has not been infected before
and, therefore, does not have immunoglobulin.
The baby's at increased risk
for hydrops or heart failure and anemia.
Sometimes, you've gotta do a red blood cell transfusion
of the infant, okay?
Transabdominally.
Intimate partner violence,
we screen all women of childbearing age regardless
of whether their symptoms are present or not.
If they screen positive,
you need to refer them for appropriate resources.
Now, this can involve sexual, physical,
verbal, psychologic abuse.
Here is what the screening questions,
definitely, you need to include, though,
have you been hit, slapped, kicked,
or otherwise, physically hurt?
Since you have been pregnant,
has this happened within the last year?
Has anybody forced you to have sexual activities?
The recommendation is to do this at eight weeks,
24 weeks, and 32 weeks.
And if they screen positive,
then follow the mandates in your state or wherever you are
in terms of branch of services.
Per ACOG, at 24 weeks gestation,
you perform a one-hour glucose tolerance test,
which is elevated at 166.
What do you do?
Repeat the one hour, have the patient see the dietician,
order a three-hour glucose tolerance test,
start low-dose metformin?
Okay, so we've done a screening test, which is positive.
Now we're gonna do a diagnostic test.
So, we get a three-hour glucose tolerance test.
Now, what's the concern about gestational diabetes?
Well, one, we're seeing it more commonly,
but importantly, it's put you at increased risk
for gestational hypertension,
one of those being preeclampsia,
increased risk of cesarean delivery
and you have an increased risk of developing diabetes
in that infant later in life.
Now, how do we detect gestational diabetes?
I want you to focus on the USPSTF 2021.
Everybody gets screened at 24 weeks.
The USPSTF says there's current evidence is insufficient
as to whether you should screen the first prenatal visit.
The ADA and the ACOG say,
yeah, you should screen at the first prenatal visit.
Now, you are looking for gestational diabetes
because it's carbohydrate intolerance first diagnosed
during pregnancy.
But basically, what you're screening for is type 2 diabetes.
And the question is, do I change the outcome by doing that?
And there, the data is insufficient.
But here are the risk factors.
As for anybody where you're looking for type 2 diabetes,
it's just it's first diagnosed during pregnancy
so by definition is gestational.
These are the risk factors
by which you would screen anyone who was younger, okay?
Now, the two-step approach is typically used
whether you're screening at the first prenatal visit
or at 24 weeks.
Remember, if you screen at the first prenatal visit
and it's negative, you would rescreen at 24 weeks
because gestational diabetes,
the risk develops as pregnancy moves forward.
We do an initial screen with a 50-gram oral glucose load.
You don't need to know the numbers.
Just know if it's abnormal,
they go on to a diagnostic evaluation.
I will tell you, if on the initial screen,
it's greater than 190, most people will not do a three-hour
because it's gonna be positive.
The three-hour oral glucose tolerance test is done
as the diagnostic test.
So you do an overnight fast, you check the blood sugar.
That's blood sugar number one of four.
You then give 'em a hundred-gram glucose load
and then you check a blood sugar one hour,
two hours, three hours.
If one over two of those values or the fasting was abnormal,
they have diagnostic criteria met for gestational diabetes
or carbohydrate intolerance first diagnosed
during pregnancy.
The screening test can be done non-fasting.
And it typically is. Patient's just there, you have it done.
Now, screening later in pregnancy, open neural tube defects,
aneuploidy, screening sonogram, anemia, and group B strep.
Okay. So neural tube defects.
Here, we're doing a maternal serum alpha-fetoprotein.
This is a blood test on mom.
If it's high, it may indicate an open neural tube defect.
This is a calculated risk.
It's most accurately done between 16 and 18 weeks.
The most common reason is I have an incorrect assignment
of the estimated gestational age, you know?
Patient comes in, "Yeah, I think I'm 20 weeks."
"Okay, we're gonna go ahead and get it today,"
or let's say 18 weeks.
But you know, in the end, she turns out to be nine weeks.
Okay, so you'd have to recalculate it
or draw it when she's 16 to 18 weeks, in that case.
Now, the aneuploidies,
this is typically done now with what's called cell-free DNA.
All pregnant women get this done.
Typically, it's done somewhere between 11 and 13 weeks
and it's done regardless of maternal age.
So you can do first-trimester screening,
you can do quadruple screening in the second trimester,
you can do integrated screening,
first and second trimesters.
These are all the possibilities.
Just know, everybody gets offered screening
for aneuploidies.
I think that would be the question on the exam, okay?
Now, if we look at screening, we've gone to cell-free DNA
because it's the most sensitive and specific
for the common fetal aneuploidies.
This is combined with an ultrasound at 18 to 22 weeks,
which we would consider our screening or anatomic survey.
Okay.
According to the CDC, all women of childbearing age
should consume how much folic acid on a daily basis?
4 milligrams, .4 milligrams, 1 milligram, or .8 milligrams?
Okay, it's .4 milligrams.
So this recommendation dates to 1992,
.4 milligrams per day.
It is estimated to reduce the risk
of neural tube defects upwards of 80%.
If there's a history of neural tube defect,
those patients should be on four milligrams per day.
Now, all you need to do is take a multivitamin once a day
'cause they all have 400 micrograms of folic acid in them.
You can't find one without that, actually.
Now, when anybody eats an enriched grain in this country,
enriched bread or whatever, it's enriched with folate.
That's what the enrichment is. No, relax your forehead.
Everybody's getting all their foreheads all crinkled up.
Don't do that here.
(attendees laughing)
So they're enriched, but the problem is,
at the enrichment level that we do in this country,
most women only get about 240 micrograms
from enriched grains.
That's why you have to be on a multivitamin.
So, you know, childbearing age,
about 12 when sexual activity starts in this country
because by 18, 50% of adolescents are sexually active,
up until about 52.
I met a woman a few weeks ago. New patient.
She's 74. Asian American, born in this country.
She was the youngest of eight children.
Her mother was 50 when she came along. Mm.
Okay.
Now, one little side of note, epilepsy,
these women seem to have an independent increased risk
for major fetal malformations.
We don't know if we can overcome it with folic acid or not,
but if you're on valproate or carbamazepine,
you need to treat them
as if they had an open neural tube defect.
They get put on four milligrams per day.
Any of the other AEDs, you get put on 800 per day.
Screening ultrasound, this is done between 16 and 20 weeks
in the absence of a specific indication.
This is what we would call the fetal anatomy survey.
You can determine the position,
movement, breathing, heart rate, fetal size, weight,
how much amniotic fluid is there, location of the placenta,
and the number of fetuses, okay?
It's not gonna find major malformay or minor malformations.
It's gonna find major ones,
but all women should be offered this
for fetal structural defects.
These can occur with or without fetal aneuploidy.
Now people argue, well, is this really screening?
What would you do?
And I understand that argument,
but it's still called a screening ultrasound.
Okay, our next question, 18-year-old G1 P0,
40 and 5/7 weeks comes in, she said,
"Oh, my membrane's ruptured 18 hours ago."
Nice. An exam confirms the rupture of membranes.
The patient is afebrile with a non-tender uterus.
Fetal heart rate tracing is reassuring.
She's not contracting.
GBS culture obtained four weeks ago was a negative.
That's group B streptococcus.
Patient has no known drug allergies.
In addition to induction of labor,
which one of the following
is the most appropriate management?
No antibiotic prophylaxis for the fetus, amp, clinda, vanc?
Correct. No antibiotic prophylaxis.
Mom's GBS negative. How can you get GBS?
So, no antibiotic prophylaxis.
Regardless of how long she's ruptured, she's GBS negative.
Okay, let's take a look at group B streptococcus.
So we do a universal screening between 36 and 0/7
and 37 and 6/7 weeks.
You're swabbing the lower two centimeters of the vagina
and then the rectum.
You use the same swab.
If they're pen allergic,
you gotta get susceptibility testing.
You get a five-week window with this culture.
That's why we told you she was four weeks since the culture.
Now, two groups do not get screened.
In the history, you find out, oh, mom had a baby
with a early onset GBS sepsis.
Okay, they don't get screened. They just get prophylaxed.
And on any culture during the pregnancy,
you found any number of CFU/mL of GBS
'cause GBS is harbored in the rectum and the sigmoid colon.
And if you got it up in your bladder,
you probably have a big burden of bacteria.
If you present in labor with an unknown status,
this is new, relatively speaking.
It used to be that's what we treated, unknown status.
Now, if you have an unknown status, but you tell me,
"Oh, in my previous pregnancy, I was colonized,"
you are offered intrapartum prophylaxis now.
Some of you're saying, well, that makes sense.
Well, that's relatively new as of 2019.
Beforehand, if you were unknown status,
we didn't ask you about what your colonization status was
in the previous pregnancy.
Now we do. They are candidates for prophylaxis.
A negative GBS culture within five weeks of delivery,
you do not prophylax the baby even if risk factors develop.
It's kind of like, how can I be in a car accident
if I'm sitting in my house, not in a car?
You can't be.
Well, if you don't have GBS positivity in the mom,
you can't get GBS to the baby.
But I don't have a culture within the past five weeks
and this is the first pregnancy.
Well, if they're delivering in less than 37 weeks
or they've been ruptured longer than 18 hours,
or they have a temp greater than 100 and 4,
then the baby gets prophylaxed.
Now, this is basically what happens.
The issue here is if I'm allergic to penicillin,
if I'm a low risk for anaphylaxis, I get cefazolin.
High risk for anaphylaxis,
I need to know the susceptibilities.
Clinda susceptible, I get clinda.
Clinda resistant, I get vanc.
Okay.
Two hours of antibiotics exposure is a minimum.
Shorter duration, we got problems.
Now, by definition, though,
adequate GBS prophylaxis is four or more hours.
So they've gotten at least one dose
and they're about to get the second
or are getting the second.
If you've had adequate,
then you observe the baby for 36 to 48 hours.
If you've had inadequate,
then that baby is going to typically have blood cultures
and empiric antibiotics.
Okay, so that there,
clinical observation for 36 to 48 hours.
Okay. Here's our next question.
26-year-old female presents with lower abdominal pain
and vaginal bleeding.
Her last menstrual period was seven weeks ago.
A urine pregnancy test is positive
and a quant hCG level is 2,500.
Transvaginal ultrasound shows no evidence
of an intrauterine gestational sac.
Baseline laboratory tests, including a CBC,
liver function, renal function, all or normal.
She's treated with a single dose of IM methotrexate.
Four days later, the patient presents for reevaluation,
and her quant now is 3,800.
Seven days later, the beta-hCG level is found to be 4,400.
Our question, which of the following is appropriate?
Give more methotrexate, get another vaginal ultrasound,
laparoscopy, expected management?
So, the correct answer is a laparoscopy with salpingostomy.
That is correct.
Everybody always chooses to repeat the ultrasound
and that's why this is a general question.
We've gotta know two numbers here.
We're talking about ectopic. What are the risk factors?
Any previous tubal surgery, sterilization, prior ectopic.
Early diagnosis is really important
because you wanna try to save that tube.
So, a salpingostomy versus salpingectomy.
Now, here are the risk factors for ectopic, okay?
Prior sterilization, previous tubal surgery.
Anything you've done to that tube,
you're gonna increase the risk.
Now, typically, these patients are gonna present
about seven weeks.
They'll get pain and then bleeding.
The diagnostic test of choice is an ultrasound,
but these are the two numbers you need to see.
If you have a hCG greater than 3,500,
you should see a gestational sac
on transabdominal ultrasound.
If you don't, you've got an ectopic until proven otherwise.
If the hCG is greater than 1,800,
you should see a gestational sac on transvaginal ultrasound.
If you don't, you have an ectopic.
So, our patient had an hCG greater than 1,800,
so there's no reason to repeat it.
You know it's ectopic.
If it were less than 1,800,
that's when you would repeat the ultrasound.
Now, beta-hCG, if it increases by doubling,
which is really 53%,
does that mean it's an intrauterine pregnancy, not ectopic?
No.
Diagnostic curettage,
if you know that the patient has an ectopic
and the hCG levels are falling,
you can do a diagnostic curettage
because if you don't have chorionic villi,
you know you have an ectopic.
Hemodynamically unstable patient,
they are going to need have an immediate surgery.
Early diagnosis and the patient is stable,
you can do medical management with methotrexate.
This is an agent, which is a folic acid antagonist,
and it inhibits DNA synthesis and cell replication.
Well, there's a lot of that going on
in this particular environment.
So, it selectively kills cytotrophoblast.
These are the rapidly dividing cells, the implantation site,
and then your body will just spontaneously reabsorb it.
We've been designed well.
Now, here's the scoop,
you measure the beta-hCG levels
on days four and seven after the methotrexate.
If the difference in decrease is greater than 15%,
you just follow it down.
If the difference in decrease is less than 15%,
you would give another dose.
If it's going up, you gotta intervene.
And that was the issue with our patient.
We'd like to do a salpingostomy.
Now, if you're doing a salpingostomy,
you may not get rid of all the products of conception,
so if a salpingostomy has been done,
or you're given that on the exam,
you've gotta check the beta-hCG level weekly till it's zero.
If you do a salpingectomy,
you go in and cut out everything,
then you've removed all the products of conception.
You can't leave anything behind.
But with the salpingostomy,
you're basically just removing the gunk, we'll call it,
like a tube, like a plumbing tube
and leaving the tube in place.
Well, that means you could leave a little bit
of residual there.
Please, in no way am I saying that that embryo is gunk.
That's not what I mean here,
but, you know, I'm just using that as an example.
Okay.
Okay. Here are the recommendations for practice.
First trimester bleeding,
ectopic, spontaneous pregnancy loss.
Chromosomal abnormalities are 50
or cause 50% of spontaneous pregnancy losses.
No bed rest/drug therapy
will correct these common etiologies.
Most women will have one spontaneous loss in their life.
A lot of them never even know it
because, you know, they're two weeks late.
"Oh (sighs), thank goodness I wasn't pregnant,"
but they really were.
Okay.
Okay, our last AES question.
For which one of the following conditions
is there good evidence
for the routine administration of anti-D immune globulin
to an unsensitized, D-negative patient?
First-trimester pregnancy loss, abdominal trauma,
second or third-trimester antenatal bleeding
or attempting an external cephalic version?
Okay, let's see here.
Good. 60% of you knew the answer.
It's after a first-trimester pregnancy loss. Okay.
So here is the scoop. Here is the level A evidence.
We give it to everybody at 28 weeks
unless you know the father of the baby
is going to be also be Rh-negative.
But you know, I've had patients come in,
you know, and argue with me.
The mother's arguing with me. "I cannot be 24 weeks."
And then the gentleman there with her says,
"Of course, she can't be 24 weeks.
We've only known each other for 10 weeks."
(attendees laughing)
Within 72 hours after the delivery of an Rh-positive infant,
if his mom is negative, first trimester's pregnancy lost
after an invasive procedure.
Level C, threatened abortion,
second or third trimester antenatal bleeding,
external cephalic version.
I love the ALSO Manual.
It says this is minimally uncomfortable for the mother.
Okay, this is like having a wrestling match with the mother
and a baby from outside.
And then any abdominal trauma. That's level C.
Practice recommendations, that's our summary.
Put those with your study materials, and we are done.
Thank you very much.
(attendees clapping)
(ethereal music)